talk is by sesh about ashes witches so
please thanks a lot
so I thanks to the organizers for for
the invitation and you know thanks to
all of you for making it on a Friday
morning so this is a supporter one
result it's a joint work with Anushka
Sharma who's now at Google but he was at
Twitter when this happened and which is
sort of central to the story and with
the Ashish coil at Stanford so just as
this is based on true story meaning that
the application I talked about is
actually an application make it happen
so that's not always the case with my
papers but and the story is sort of it's
like some big data problem which
actually led to some theory which
actually led to some practice so it was
actually it's a nice example for me
where the whole story was sort of
completed so maybe it's not something
completely different but it was
different for me
so usually as an algorithms person when
I try to work with someone who's applied
you know I will go I will talk with them
learn about the problem think about it
for a while and say you know what I have
this amazing algorithm for your problem
it's two times faster than previous work
here I actually coded it up I have some
things I have some nice theory and so
that's that's me on the side I don't
have a hat because I'm not that
important and I don't make as much money
and so the applied person will say well
I just bought a cluster with five times
on memory I don't care I'm just gonna
use my old code and say you know I've
just I've engineered my code so much
that if you give me 2x speed-up it's
just not worth it and it's usually true
because there's a lot of effort that
goes into engineering and system
building which often sort of you know
gives bigger wins than a new algorithmic
idea and so what is the problem I'm
specifically talking about here it's
very simple as we've talked about
various variants of nearest neighbor
search or vet vector problems I'm given
a bunch of n non-negative vectors in R
to the D so high dimensional space and I
want all pairs that are similar and
similar I'll measure by cosine
similarity
meaning that the similarity between two
vectors U and V is just the cosine of
the angle between them or is the
normalized dot product and one of the
problems that comes up in in
recommendation systems is and it's
actually one of the key feature in a in
a recommendation system at Twitter is
you want to find all pairs of people or
objects that are similar to each other
and this will be then fed into some
pipeline and this is sort of you know
it's an offline job so it's not like
your nearest neighbor where you think of
it as you know your pre process and then
you get inquiries here it's more of you
have this data and then you produce all
pairs that are similar and one of the
important things we'll use is that
common representations are non-negative
and maybe if I didn't I should specify
that again there M non negative vector
is in high dimensional space and so this
is the problem that we want to study so
another way of sort of phrasing this is
I'm given n non-negative unit vectors in
R to the D so I'll think of these as the
columns of this matrix and I'm given
some threshold tau and I want to find
all pairs of columns or vectors U and V
such that U dot V is more than tough the
dot product is more than tau and
equivalently if I'm given a matrix a I'm
looking at the grameen matrix a
transpose a and I want all entries that
are more than tau so this is the problem
and they're non-negative so this is what
we're going to study and this was one of
those examples where instead of me
coming up with a better algorithm and
trying to sell it to the applied person
the apply person says I have no
algorithm and no system that works at
scale and specifically if N and D are
about a billion so that's the number of
vectors and the dimension of the space
and the number of non-zeros in the
matrix so this is a sparse matrix so the
number of non-zeros is usually on the
average maybe it's about a hundred per
column but there's a lot of skew in the
data the number of non-zeros is about
more than ten billion then at least
atwitter there was no system solution
like essentially yeah many of them
belike interesting for you lighter than
threshold how many of them would be more
than the threshold so on the average
let's say about 10 200 per vector so
maybe about the total number of pairs
you'll get is maybe 10 billion or 100
billion wait how was it like the number
of zeros how is it larger than then why
does it have to do I mean it's it's
similar
Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya
it can be much much more than this so
the output actually is quite large I
mean so okay so I should say that this
is not the phrasing that they chose they
would choose the phrasing that says
which is similar maybe to more of how
you would phrase nearest neighbors give
me the top 10 nearest neighbors for
every vertex but it then becomes like as
Rasmus talked about yesterday it becomes
hard to talk about precision and recall
in those settings and with this it's
easier to define precision in recall and
sort of also to benchmark the algorithm
and so I'll come back to what is the
value of tau that is relevant for this
problem because that becomes central to
the challenges and so there was no
system solution being that essentially
what was used was sort of various hacky
algorithms and it was known that they're
not going to converge and this is this
is where you know it seemed like there
was a new algorithmic idea that was
required and so the result we have is
okay it's called wimp because you know
this was a dub dub dub you have to come
up with some stupid acronym to describe
an algorithm so sorry but it's basically
a MapReduce algorithm for finding
similar vectors and it has a
theoretically near optimal shuffle or
communication which I will explain and
it's practically viable that it actually
worked on this instance with okay the
reason I put OHS there is because I'm
not allowed to disclose exactly how many
edges or vertices they have but
basically that's how so it's it works on
you know a matrix which is about a
hundred billion non zeros without
killing your cluster so it works in a
day which which is reasonable and you
know the way to think about this is a
hundred billion is about a terabyte so
that you could barely store on a very
large machine
but if any intermediate work you do
start blowing up then you have to
distribute the work and instead of
getting into sort of the guts of
MapReduce it's more convenient to just
to think of a sort of abstract
communication model you can enumerate
the non-zeros but the number of pairs I
mean how do you find which are the ones
that are similar because you want all
dot products that are above a threshold
there are sparse but you know it's the
average degree would be about a hundred
but it starts varying there's skew and
so because of that like you can you
could basically let's say you find some
vector here which has let's say a
hundred to a thousand non zeros I mean
you can't go and look up everything else
that in the same in the same row which
which has that neighbors that makes the
contours of the variable Y don't so why
don't I give you the exact description
of the application then maybe it'll
maybe it'll be clearer I mean what
you're suggesting is it you just solve
matrix multiplication exactly yeah and
that's too much actually and I'll show
you numbers to show that's too much so
okay let me give the following somewhere
abstract model so here is my matrix so
these are the vectors I'm looking at I'm
going to represent this just a bi as a
bipartite graph so these are the rows
and these are the columns right and so
technically these are indexing the
vectors this is indexing the dimension
and it's important that you know I we
fixed this because I'll be using this
later on so just that on the right side
are the vectors on the left side are the
dimensions so I'm looking at similarity
between any two objects over here and in
effect you know the whatever the vector
is given just by the neighborhood and
you can think of there's a separate
machine that stores the neighborhood
here and that stores the neighborhood
here
the model clear so okay so I'm see I'm
just thinking of this as the adjacency
list of a bipartite graph and now every
machine stores one of those lists and
that's what I should have said right so
essentially every machine here
stores a column every machine here
stores a row okay and of course there
could be some way there's some weight on
this and it's convenient just for us to
think about there being synchronous
communication amongst edges so in every
phase there's some communication along
the edges and this can be simulated in
MapReduce by you know it's it's
relatively easy and the total
communication is also the total shuffle
cost and MapReduce so what I want to
bound is how much communication there's
happening also I will talk about running
time but it's actually much of this
computation is communication bound not
exactly CPU bound any questions about
what the model is yeah you're right it's
it it'll be convenient when we describe
the algorithm think about this way but
actually they can actually communicate
with anybody but it turns out that that
is really what is relevant you just to
simplify what's happening and again this
isn't really the actual model of
computation that's under the hood but
it's it's a good proxy for what's
happening in MapReduce okay all right so
there's there's been a lot of previous
work I mean it's just matrix
multiplication so you know their exact
systems called like Blas and sees parts
which are surprisingly good there's a
lot of approximate matrix multiplication
result like you know genius Canon
Mahoney work mice are lower so on and so
forth there's a lot of work on LSH which
is relevant to this because in effect
the dot product problem is basically
nearest neighbor search when you
restrict everything to be on the unit
sphere and so Alex and Ilya talked about
some work yesterday and one of the
specific papers I want to mention is is
Antoni in de Clairvaux van rossum
Shyne and schmidt which was effectively
solving you know coming up with LSH new
hash functions for this problem and then
there's also a line of work on pot
sampling which I'll get into but the
problem is you know we were trying to
apply in these things maybe sort of out
of the box and just seeing you know is
any of this going to work and the
problem ends up being that there's just
too much communication so it's not that
the running time is bad you can maybe
afford to distribute all the work but
communication along the edges was too
much and so our main goal years try to
reduce the communication to solve this
problem now before I get into the guts
of what actually happened so there's
this quote of Giancarlo rota which says
philosophers and psychiatry should
explain why it is that we mathematicians
are in the habit of systematically
erasing our footsteps which is you read
a paper and you have no idea why they
got to that so let me tell you about a
race footstep that's not talked about in
the paper so what's the problem the
problem actually comes up at Twitter
where you say that two people are
similar if the followers intersect so me
and the minion are similar because in
the Twitter graph which is basically who
follows whom if there is a relatively
low if there's an intersection between
us then that's some sign of similarity
and you can measure similarity by just
saying that it's the intersection of the
sets divided by some by some
normalization so cosine similarity is
just some normalized intersection so
this is a reasonable measure of
similarity now domain studies show that
similarities of 0.15 to point to matter
meaning that a 15% of my followers also
follow you and Twitter that's usually
some sign that we're similar now I'll
show you some some numbers on that now
the reason why this becomes relevant so
maybe now does this answer your question
as to why you can enumerate all the set
intersections because you would
basically if if you try to solve this
exactly then you would be enumerated
every possible path of length two in
this graph and that's too much yeah if
you look at a lot of the literature on
low dimensional projections and hashing
and nearest neighbor and you dig into
what they're doing they're usually
trying to detect similarities of more
than 0.8 right because we're looking at
dot products at most one so 0.8 is
similar and so things like LSH are
extremely good for deduplication where
you're looking at new similarity but in
recommendation systems where
similarities of point 1 to point 3
matter then the performance degrades
significantly when you were there and to
give you an example I mean this was a
paper in dub-dub-dub so we had to give
these examples if you look at the
Twitter handle of dub-dub-dub 2016 and
it looked at a bunch of other
conferences the similarity score ranges
from 0.26 to 0.15 and you can see that
they're all similar and we took a bunch
of like you know network scientists
Duncan Watts a dynamic bar owashi array
let's go back and the similarity between
their follower is about 0.2 this is just
to say that you know 0.2 to 0.1 is a
reasonable threshold of similarity for
things that are obviously
semantically similar and when you dig
into the math you know that to find
similarities of tau you need 1 over tau
square work or pain or communication or
some such suffering which is quadratic
in tau and so what happens a
well-engineered solution for tau equals
0.9 this is usually if you're doing some
sort of low dimensional projection then
you get a 1 over tau square you may log
in over tau square but then there's a
tau Square and so a well and so and
obviously you know you take a solution
like this you have to engineer it and if
you engineer it for tau equals point or
it fails miserably for tau equals 0.2
because there's that much more pain and
so in some sense the real theoretical
contribution is we give an algorithm
which find similarities of tau where the
total communication is the following so
it's so here's the number of pairs whose
similarity is greater than tau so this
is the lower bound on the output and
this is multiplied by tau to the minus 1
and then you look at the number of
non-zeros in the matrix and this is
multiplied by tau to the minus 2 so
there is a tower the minus 2 pain but it
multiplies a quantity that is somewhat
smaller and if you look at the
communication in previous algorithms
that tau to the minus 1 and tau to the
minus 2 multiplied larger quantities so
this is this is sort of a cartoon of the
main theorem and the the hard part was
to basically try to get this tau to the
minus 1 multiplying
the larger quantity in the in the
communication any question yeah that's
exactly yeah that is the out yeah so
which is also a load one on the other
yeah it's equality and therefore it's
also good yeah it is the output alright
so I talked about the distributed
framework so how did we actually begin
to try to solve this problem so let me
actually tell you about a method called
wet sampling which was invented by Cohan
and Lewis and then rediscovered in four
different three different subsequent
works one of them is unfortunately mine
and then you know we did this ten years
later and say oh these guys actually
solved it and so this was a sort of
paper in 2000 in 1999 so that is very
neat algorithm that says of you you're
given a matrix a you're going to do
pre-processing which is linear in a so
number of nonzero time pre-processing
you're going to build a data structure a
randomized data structure and now you
can push a button so over one time it
generates a wedge which is a path of
length two in this graph in this matrix
the guarantee is the probability that I
and J are the ends is proportional to
the dot product of VI and VJ so it's a
sort of important sampler so in linear
time you build this data structure and
then you push a button and it will
generate a path of length two at random
and the end points I and J are they're
proportional to V I dot B J and I'm
assuming on item entries yes yes
non-negative entries and so let me
actually tell you how it works so
remember we represented this matrix as
as this bipartite graph that's a now let
me stick a transpose there so a and a
transpose obviously you know the rows of
the columns of a transpose or the rows
away so these are the dimensions and
these are just indexing the vectors now
for any edge I have a way that's a RI
and the weight of this is I sorry this
is the weight a RI this is the weight a
RJ now let's say the weight of a path is
the product of these weights and you
know it's sort of the obvious thing that
the sum over parts from I to
actually give you the dot product of VI
and VJ gives you that entry in the
matrix product and so what you need to
do is simply sample a path proportional
to its weight and the probability of
getting I and J would be proportional to
the dot product so this is what you need
to do it as long as you can so and the
non-negativity is used because I'm
saying sample a path proportional to
weight this is not defined if things are
negative and so any any questions about
this so the the core Lewis trick which
you know if you sit and think about it
for a while you you know you'll come up
with is to you pre-process to compute
for each vertex in the middle compute
the sum of these weights so let's just
say the weight of R is the sum of these
entries okay and then you simply sample
okay so I I fudged over here so I should
have said WR is actually the square of
this quantity I mean it's the weight of
this times the weight of all of these so
that's like the total weight of the
parts of length two that go through that
vertex right so now you simply sample
are proportional to that weight it
should be the square of this quantity
and then once you do that you can then
pick a neighbor proportional to its own
or to its value over here and you do the
same thing over here and you'll get a
path which is proportional to the total
weight is there any questions let me
know if nothing else I hope you just
learned this because a very neat trick
because linear time you pre-process the
matrix and now in constant time or
depending on your model of bits in
constant or logarithmic time you can
actually output IJ proportional to the
dot product so it's like okay this is a
great idea so what you can do and
actually this is what Sade and Boyle did
later on is to say well you can also do
this in a sort of distributed setting
you can set it up in sort of MapReduce
or in this distributed setting where now
you look at all the vertices on the
right so again now I want to think of
just this as instead of thinking of it
as a path in the tripartite graph let me
just fold it back so this is a path of
length 2 over here
sort of the same thing and so you're
generating these pots of length to so
you could think of the green machine
here is gonna generate a bunch of wedges
with the green vertex in the center the
red vertex generates a bunch of these
them the yellow vertex generates those
and now essentially this was an
important sample you were able to sample
I J proportional to the dot product so
if you collect all the wedges that you
sampled you would see the more frequent
the more similar things more often right
so you can collect all the parts of
length two that are generated through
all of this and you say oh look I J
appeared here here and here therefore I
J is probably similar so so that's
that's you know this is the algorithm of
Zadeh and good it's basically just
saying you take the cohen lewis trick
and then you do a distributed
implementation of it now what you need
is a shuffle or communication of all the
wedges that are generated because that's
how you will collect and figure out who
are the ones that are coming so you can
say how many wedges do you need to
actually catch you know VI dot V J's
greater than tau so now let's do the
calculation so I said you know a wedge
with IJ is generated proportional to VI
dot VJ so let's just figure out what the
proportionality constant is that's just
the sum of VI dot VJ over all IJ which
makes sense right that's that's the
that's sort of the ambient space from
which you're sampling I and J was the
distribution over ours the distribution
over ours well then I think for our
application is not going to matter
because all of those weights will be the
same but I think in general it's going
to be you know it depends on the length
of yeah it depends actually probably on
the weight of that path because it's
generating parts uniformly it's
generating parts proportional to their
weight yeah so so yeah so this is the
proportionality constant here and this
is just the sum of all dot products or
similarities so which you know it really
is the you know the matrix one or
involved it's the one on of all entries
in a transpose a it's just like the sum
of all the dot products
okay any questions so yeah this is easy
to turn around you say how if you want
VI dot VJ well the number of samples you
need is basically the reciprocal of that
more times ten for convergence for us
convergence is tight let's login so you
want large entries you only want the
problem is you only want the large
entries but you pay something linear in
the total sum of dot products but the
nice thing is that you have a one over
tau dependence so now the question is
you know how does this work out so you
know it's sort of if you just think of
this is the space of all dot products
here is a large dot product here as a
small one and you're basically throwing
darts into this board obviously you will
hit this much more often than you'll hit
that except the problem is there's
there's a lot of noise and there's only
a little bit of signal and so there are
lots of small entries that tend to drown
out the few large entries and most of
the communication tends to be noise
again just to give you some specific
numbers so these are three like
benchmark matrices that are out there
with N and E the dimension it ranges
from millions to billions so flock is
actually the Twitter graph I'm not a lot
yeah it's it's it's o of 1 billion so if
you look at what is a transpose a the
one norm so there's actually not rhythm
to compute this you know you can compute
it and then you can say your total
shuffle for computing tau being point
two is you know ten times up for
convergence divided by town two times
sixteen bytes because you know every
wedge is like a pair of lungs and so you
have sixteen bytes so you can get some
sort of back of the envelope calculation
of how much shuffle this algorithm is
going to do and you sort of plug it in
and you get that for the Twitter graph
you need to shuffle 18,000 terabytes
just by looking and that's how many were
you know and even for something which is
fairly small you need like 200 to 600
terabytes a single round of MapReduce on
the Twitter cluster would handle about
200 terabytes just to give you a sense
of what's going on so you can engineer
the heck out you can try to engineer
these and maybe you'll get it on say
instead of a long I'll username
then I'll squeeze some bits over here
and divide the work up but for a graph
for the Twitter graph this is just way
beyond what what you could engineer and
there's no system solution so one of the
reasons do this calculation was it tell
people like look you know there's no way
you're gonna buy another system that's
gonna solve the problem and so we were
stuck here for for a long time and
because you know and then we waited try
engineering in various ways until at
some point there was you know we were
sitting down and now we start thinking
like a theorist you say well ok let's
let's suppose there's some article is
there some article that could help us
solve this problem and suppose there is
this magic Oracle who could just tell us
what the dot product was if you asked
for any IJ give me VI dot VJ let's say
this Oracle would tell you the answer so
this is locally generating a bunch of
wedges which then it has to communicate
but the Wed generation for this is local
right because it knows its neighborhood
and so for each wedge it could ask or
what is VI dot BJ the Oracle says oh
it's more than tau says ok of course I
have to put this and you could ask for
another I prime J prime you know what is
that and if the Oracle said no this is
actually less than tau I say I don't
need to output that so if you had an
Oracle that will actually tell you which
are the dot products which are large
then you could obviously output that and
then in this case only the wedges where
VI dot BJ is greater than tau would be
communicated but you know you could say
but isn't designing the Oracle the
problem itself I mean what's going on
here and it turns out that now so just
to remind you of the setting again you
know this is the bipartite graph that
represents a matrix these are the
vectors these are the dimensions and the
dimensions I've colored so each eye over
here so each machine here knows this
vector right this is vector VI dot BJ so
here's something that is obvious if the
green node here knew all of these
vectors and the green node here is
generating your edges if it knew what
all these vectors are it could construct
the Oracle itself but if
that's just exact matrix multiplication
because if this thing actually knew all
these vectors then you're actually
implicitly generating all paths of
length two which is the matrix product
and so is there some way we can kind of
compress these and send it to that so it
could just locally build the Oracle and
there was sort of an aha moment and said
well you know this is where you know we
could try to to use hashing methods from
LSH or something to basically compress
these and send that compress sketch
which then this vertex over here could
get those compressed caches and then
build the Oracle itself
I'll just show that again because it
took a long time for me to get that to
work right so there each word vertex
over here machine over here generates a
compression off the vector and sends
that compression over to the left and
then this can then build the Oracle and
so the green node would collect all the
sketches and then simulate the Oracle
using them and so what is the sketch we
use well you know we use Charlie Kerr
sim hash because we're looking at dot
products so what a sim hash do some hash
just says if you have two vectors VI dot
VJ if you pick a random vector then your
hash is a one bit hash which is simply
the sign of the dot product and so in
this case the hash of VI would be one
and the hash of VJ would be zero and
it's a single bit hash and the
probability that the hash values the
same is one minus theta divided by pi
where theta is the angle between them
and so the hashing scheme is you know
you basically just rinse and repeat k
times to get some kind of sketch so you
do this a bunch of times and you're
gonna get some sort of hash and the
Hamming distance between the hashes is
some measure of the angle and you know
just you know just to be a little formal
so the Hamming distance is some binomial
where K is the number of times you
repeated this then it's a binomial you
know with with the parameter theta over
pi and so if the vectors are orthogonal
if the vectors are orthogonal then
actually this is 1/2 right so it's just
standard binomial and you know you can
kind of do the math
apply the cosines and everything and so
now let's just say what is the hash
length that we need if you have two
vectors that are orthogonal versus two
vectors where the cosine similarity is
Theta is tau then the angle between them
is roughly like PI over 2 times 1 minus
tau so it's it's just and you know you
just do the Chernoff bound roughly you
need 1 over tau square flips to
distinguish them and this is where the
tau square pops up and you know this
sort of this is the pain now because you
have to detect orthogonality from sort
of near orthogonality and you need the 1
over tau squared not the 1 over tau and
so this tells us of a hashed length of
roughly 1 over tau square you can
determine similarities of 1 over tau and
now you kind of plug it all together so
for each vertex over here it has to sort
of generate these hashes so technically
you can think of each vertex on the left
generates a Gaussian and then would send
that Gaussian over here and then this
can then compute those dot products and
you know the thing is you don't I won't
do that again because you see you saw
that trick already but so as long as
each of these generates a Gaussian then
this over the machine over here knows
the vector and can actually generate the
sort of dot product and you know I'll
spare you some of the details of how you
actually you know how you do this but
effectively the way it works is each
processor on the right computes this
hash and this if you use you know
pseudo-random generators this just
requires number of non-zeros
communication so it's quite cheap so you
generate all of these hashes then each
vertex on the left will collect all the
hashes from its neighbors and the
communication here is the number of non
zero so every edge is sending a hash of
length login over tau squared so all the
hashes are collected and then finally
each of these runs the sort of the Cohen
Lewis trick it generates a bunch of
wedges so every time it generates a
wedge you can look up the hashes to get
some estimate of what the dot product is
and then you know based on what the
estimate is it can
either ignore it or output it so the
nice thing is that anything that is
output after this is a genuine is
actually similar so any any questions on
that
yeah it's right instead of like
independent inspectors generate like
random orthogonal matrix I think it
usually works quite a bit better oh it's
an interesting no we actually didn't try
that but maybe it doesn't matter for you
too much but you can actually like my
Curtis way to be far it's interesting so
actually in this case what we do is we
don't you know so actually none of these
actually sends a Gaussian because this
already knows what its neighborhood so
if it uses a pseudo-random generator
using that as a seed if you just do it's
about just making okay making that yeah
yeah I think that would be that would be
interesting so the number of
communicative communication the final
step is actually the only thing that is
output is actually a pair that is
similar but there's an extra towel
inverse log n because the same pair
could be generated multiple times and so
if you go through the math you see that
it's actually there's some repetition
there which is necessary to use this
image for pockets in order use it for
sketching we're using it for sketching
there's no bucketing that's happening
here
it's using so once this vertex here has
the same hashes of all of these it's it
can sort of build this Oracle itself for
any to word in any to I for any I and J
it can determine whether V I got V J's
above a threshold okay so the benefit is
is instead of sending setting the do
they hold like the original they say you
said this sorta you yeah exactly
so yeah that's all so in the end you
know it's not that fancy you basically
plug in come on Louis you plug in this
thing and you stitch it together and
then you yeah so focusing first so
bucket I mean so we had tried that but
then there the problem with a one so
actually David and I were discussing
this in some naive ways if you do the
bucketing then looking at all pairs in
the bucket is too much
and then if you want to do sort of
vanilla LSH the problem is you need
technically super linear sort of space
totally and then that communication will
then kill you so the thing is the same
higher sketches here are SH not large
enough to do bucketing they're much
shorter than that because they're only
of length log n over tau squared right
typically you would need something like
n to the RO to Bay be able to the
bucketing I could be I hope I'm not miss
peeking yeah
this is basically so to make sure that
you get conversions
you have to generate more wedges than
exactly what is required is logon over
tau it's the tau tau in Versailles it's
login over tau yeah there's a typo so
you know there's some work that's
required maybe the important things to
mention or you know you can say the sort
of precision recall type result saying
that if anything is if we output
something then significant if something
is significant then it will be output
and there's something with the
communication costs and the hashes so
I'll sort of skip all of this and maybe
I'll show you there is one caveat that
that's there which is so on the right on
the left side we actually remove all
vertices which have extremely high
degree because it turns out in the
application
those are spammers those are people who
follow everybody and this actually in
effect is removing dimensions that
participating too many vectors it
reduces the skew in communication so it
actually helps us and the Mayall so
maybe come back to this in a couple of
minutes sorry so the important thing to
note is that well you know in the
experiments this is sort of the
estimated shuffle cost if you just try
to shuffle all the wedges and this is
what we get so something is eighteen
thousand terabytes comes to two hundred
terabytes or three hundred terabytes
which is reasonable having an
interesting plot over here is just to
see what all the what is the ratio of
the various things so so this is think
of this as the total communication and
the red part is just the sketches
that's the hashes that are being sent
and the green part are the actual
candidates that are output like you uh
you know for every where did you check
locally whether it's above a threshold
and you send it and then of course there
are certain ideas which are repeated so
you compress that to get the output so
the output is actually about about 10%
of the total communication so clearly
there's a lot of extra stuff that's
happening and any savings over here
would be useful and so maybe you know
what you were suggesting about
compressing the hashes would be useful
there was easy to work with engineers
that means never use render render this
so I you know Annie she's good at that
like he yeah but this was so large a
problem that they they kind of accepted
they accepted the curse of randomness
but that was all Anisha not yeah so let
me just sort of tell you about some of
the open problems that are still left
over here actually many of them one is
exactly what I said that if you look at
the communication that a specific node
gets it gets all the hashes of its
neighbors and so it's order of D times
tau inverse log n without the minus 2
I'm sorry where D is actually its degree
now we actually remove the high degree
vertices because in that application we
could but in general you cannot and
there are certain other applications
where the degrees are actually very
large in which case what this does even
the total communication is lower the
maximum communication at a particular
node is high enough to kill the problem
and it would be nice to have an
alternate scheme that I can actually
bound the maximum communication like
something where maybe D could even be
something like let's say o of N or
something that is just barely little o
of N and yet can we still get the
communication to be smaller the other
thing and I guess to some extent is what
alia was talking about is you know our
sketch was actually one kilobyte so it's
8,000 bits that's 8,000 same hash runs
and it barely distinguishes you know
something that's orthogonal from a dot
product of 0.1 and better sketches would
be very
like even if you could save some
constant factor with a clever sketch
that would reduce the significantly or
we could use the same sketch to detect
things that are you know even you know
we could we could improve that threshold
and that would be very useful
moving from more theoretical standpoint
the uses of non negativity were
interesting because I think any sort of
anything that's based on that is
rotation invariant is not using
negativity so the fact that the Cohen
Lewis trick actually uses the
representation is interesting you know
Ilya and Alex have done things with data
dependent hashing but there is more of
using low dimensional structure and it
would be nice if there's some principled
way of using the non-negativity and you
know in general you know what is the
complexity of this problem I don't know
maybe people have already I haven't dug
enough into the literature but you want
to find all large entries maybe just in
a transpose a where a is non-negative is
there some well good understanding of
the complexity smells like some fine
drain complexity problem so yeah in this
case actually they were they were floats
because you normalized yeah but they
were originated so it's a binary matrix
it's a graph but then you
yeah it's binary but then you normalize
it so it's 0 1 yeah yeah because you
take a graph and then you're looking at
it's actually set intersection but
you're normalizing it so that's what
creates the floats but then it turns out
we don't even use the binary part of it
yeah which is also interesting so I'm
out of time and so I will just end with
the most interesting man in the world
Thank You time for one or two questions
yeah so when you're like thank you focus
on on what could walk in fact this which
is very nice in there but like but that
mean is a thing like the direction of
suppose this people first network was
actually like highly easily clustered
into some way then you could potentially
so the program like you know what
happened one of the hundred times that's
a very interesting thought so we had you
know we were toying with weather so
maybe a different way of phrasing that
is it might be too expensive to cluster
the original data but it could be that
that implies that the similarity has
enough structure that you can exploit
that in the algorithm itself if it's
cluster well of something you actually
use less likely you know like a instance
so actually one of the things that we
observed I mean we is that it's
reasonably often there if you know if
I'm similar to somebody and that person
is similar to someone else then we are
also similar and so what could be the
cases you could set out to be fairly
large just get some candidates and then
just explore amongst that to find the
other candidates but I think will be
really nice to actually even
theoretically formalize that and like
and try to analyze that
so exploiting sort of some sort of
transitive structure in the in the
nearest neighbor graph or something like
that yeah
other questions so I was wondering did
you did you consider kind of
communication complexity lower bound for
this kind of problems I mean no not yet
nine and I yeah I haven't I think there
will be some interesting things to be
proving here one thing is you know is
this core Lewis trick somehow optimal in
some way in that you know it basically
you get this important sampler for the
entries can you can you actually sample
large entries even better using linear
time pre-processing I don't know if
that's a well posed question but
something like that yeah
thanks again
[Applause]